c'est une nouvelle compétence donc nous
devons déjà nous avons oublié de cette
compétence là vous fédérer les 18
communes autour du tourisme est déjà la
première chose et deuxièmement nous
avons des atouts formidables dans le nom
donc notre mission à cet office du
tourisme de faire en sorte que ces
atouts la devient des produits testés et
que le nom puisse avoir une vision plus
globale du tourisme et qu'on ne puisse
ont fait en sorte que ce tourisme la
prospérité pour tous le nom le premier
bouger ses doigts structurer cette
épique puisque vous avez que c'est tout
nouveau
avant chaque commune organisée sur son
territoire mais tant d'arrogance 70
victoires donc nous devons mettre en
place des structures qui puisse
permettre de couvrir l'ensemble du
territoire
deuxième deuxième objectif de faire en
sorte que ce territoire puissent
bénéficier de la peau de nos visiteurs
et conclusions proposées de manière
assez intelligent ce que notre
territoire regorge de richesses et
d'autres réseaux au sein de l'opposition
quizz du nom nous avons organisé l'achat
de telle sorte qu'il y ait trois bassins
de vie si vous voulez les trois bassins
donc à chaque bassin novillo à travers
un pays tu es là d'un bureau
d'information touristique qui va prendre
le relais sur le territoire et ce but au
juste mais composé des élus de la
commune des communes qui constituent son
territoire ça l'est pour sociaux pose
d'elle du territoire et de telle sorte
que ces trois belles idées puissent
pouvoir
animer ce qu'on appelle un comité local
du tourisme et ce comité local des twins
à venir alimenter le comité directeur du
tourisme du nord qui en sort que les
choses puissent sortir vraiment de la
souche pour pouvoir remonter pour avoir
organisé et synthétiser